(CHEERING)
CROWDS ARE SUPER JUMBO FIRED UP
FOR MARCH MADNESS.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A SHORT
CLIP OF A FAN DANCING, AND YOUR
JOB IS TO NAME THAT DANCE.
FIRST UP, WE HAVE AN IMPROMPTU
DANCE-OFF BETWEEN THIS YOUNG
PISTONS FAN AND AN USHER.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
HOW DID IT END?
I WANT TO KNOW HOW IT ENDS.
MEGAN NEURINGER.
>> THAT TIME WE BRIEFLY FORGOT
THAT WE LIVED IN DETROIT.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: DAMN!
POINTS!
(LAUGHTER)
WHEN YOU PLAY BON JOVI ON THE
EAST COAST, YOU KNOW IT'S GOING
TO BE A WINNER, SO CHECK THIS
KID OUT.
>> ♪ WE GOTTA HOLD ON
TO WHAT WE GOT... ♪
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: MEGAN NEURINGER.
>> THE "LIVING ON A PRAYER
THAT I WILL ONE DAY HAVE SEX."
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WELL, IF YOU LOOK
REALLY CLOSELY HE'S ABOUT TO
(BLEEP) THAT POLE RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT'S NOT CONSENSUAL.
>> Chris: IT'S NOT CONSENSUAL.
>> IT DOESN'T COUNT!
>> OH MY GOD!
>> Chris: NEXT ONE: HOW ABOUT A
LITTLE BELLY DANCE ACTION, GUYS?
HERE'S A LITTLE BELLY DANCE.
(LAUGHING)
>> Chris: PROOPS.
>> THE UN(BLEEP)ABLE WHITE
GUY?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: YEAH, I'LL GIVE YOU
POINTS BUT I BEG TO DIFFER.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PLACES
TO STICK IT IN THERE.
ALL RIGHT, THAT IS THE END
OF JUMBOTRON DANCE-OFF.
I KNOW, I'M SAD TO SEE IT GO.
MAN, THIS SHOW NEEDS
A JUMBOTRON DANCE-OFF SO PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE CAN BE LIKE...
(CHEERING)
"#HASHTAGWARS!"
(APPLAUSE)
I THINK I JUST THREW
MY DICK OUT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> YOU SHOULD RECYCLE.
>> Chris: 100 POINTS!
(APPLAUSE)
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
IS THERE A VERY SMALL DOCTOR
IN THE HOUSE?
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)